un convoi de dizaines de camions et de
blindés équipés d'artillerie lourde nous
sommes dans la région de brest en
biélorussie à une cinquantaine de
kilomètres seulement de la frontière
avec l'ukraine selon ces images tournées
par le ministère de la défense russe aux
soldats au sol s'ajoutent les nombreux
avions de chasse un déploiement de force
dans le cadre d'exercices militaires
conjoints prévus du 10 au 20 février
ce mercredi le voisin lituaniens ne
cachait pas son inquiétude
je dirais que le nombre de soldats
approche rapidement dans les trente
mille
on se rapproche très vite et il est
évident que toutes ces forces sont
dirigés vers le sud toutes ces forces
sont dirigées contre l'ukraine
trente mille soldats russes soit quatre
fois plus que lors des exercices
habituels de récentes images satellite
montrent aussi ce qui ressemble à des
lanceurs de missiles déployés près de
yale sq à 200 kilomètres de kiev
l'exercice en biélorussie qui n'est pas
loin de l'endroit où nous parlons
aujourd'hui est extrêmement préoccupant
il s'agit en effet d'un exercice massif
comprenant non seulement un grand nombre
de troupes russes mais aussi des
capacités
c'est pourquoi nous faisons de notre
mieux de la manière la plus sincère et
la plus ouverte pour emprunter la voie
de la diplomatie
la voie de la diplomatie seule issue
possible côté ukrainien où l'on tente de
minimiser ce renfort de troupes et des
manoeuvres aux frontières côté américain
on accuse moscou de poursuivre l'
escalade avec un nouveau renfort de
troupes observée ces dernières heures à
la frontière est de l'ukraine où déjà
plus de cent mille soldats ont été
prépositionnés